I own 13 portfolio companies and in one
of them I unlocked $6 million of
Enterprise Value in 60 days by solving
three problems and I did it with data so
this is actually a sequel video and you
may remember our three wise men they
came and they were sad because they had
problems that they wanted to fix and
they're already making twice as much
money just from the fixes that we did
from the sales so we went from 56 units
per month sold to 93 units again in 60
days and so the problem that we
encountered after we doubled the sales
now they had twice as many people going
to get fulfilled on whatever ever the
thing is that they sold what was once
shaky had completely been obliterated
because it was already tough when they
had the current amount but with double
they were completely lost so one of the
never ending issues in business is that
there's something called the problem
solution cycle it works like this you
got problems you've got Solutions that's
ugly as anyways so the problem is
when you solve a problem with a solution
you then create another problem so if I
10x your sales what's the next problem
going to be and so we had to fix that
problem now we wanted to track these
three stats because they didn't even
have LTV track the the first was time to
First value the second was customer
satisfaction and then we had our
Ascension rates or the absolute amount
of money that they were making on the
back end which is after someone buys the
first thing they buy the second thing
right so let's start with where they
were at and by the way this e is not
something fancy it just should be there
but y'all are cool so we we'll go with
it all right time to First value is a
really interesting statistic it's
probably one of the one of the ones that
I care the most about in any kind of
service so in the world of content like
watching TV there's different shows that
you might watch
so each show they calculate an actual
retention point and so Breaking Bad for
example is one of the best shows of all
time they found that if someone made it
to the third episode they had like an
87% likelihood of finishing the entire
Five Seasons if they got to that point
and so different shows have a different
retention point that hooks the viewer
for the Long Haul and so that's what
we're ultimately driving towards you can
call it a retention point you can call
it activation you can call it whatever
you want but there's a key moment that
transforms the customer relationship
into a long-term commitment with you and
what your goal is to pull that as for
far forward to the present as you
possibly can you don't have to deliver
the ultimate result immediately I mean
the faster you can do that the better
but what you want to do is break it into
many small chunks and show leading
indicators of success so in other words
progress and the more times that you can
break down an outcome into tinier chunks
the more reinforced the customer will be
for staying with you so for example if I
was in a high touch agency so I did
marketing services for someone and let's
say we touch base once every two weeks
right now I do a lot of things between
those two weeks for the customer but if
every two weeks I correspond with them
then they're going to get reinforced
every 2 weeks for me doing stuff now
consider a different way of doing it I
onboard them and then every day I send
them what I did to work on their behalf
at the end of that 2 weeks they would
have had 14 different positive
interactions with me versus one you can
take what you're currently doing not
change much about it and simply
communicate it differently so that they
can perceive a faster time to First
value value that's the idea here for
example in the gym launch world in the
beginning it was if we can get someone
to do a high ticket sale in the first 7
days it would triple the LTV for us so
then instead of trying to think about
churn or any of these metrics we said
let's just try and make sure every
single person gets that sale as fast as
possible and so that's what we'd measure
the way that we eventually would go to
was how quickly they would launch an
internal campaign for us and how much
they generated from that so our goal
then became how quickly can we get them
to send the emails that we want them to
send that's two different examples of
different time to First values and
without further Ado let us show you the
before data so for the time to First
value was 47 days got to improve that
imagine you buy something and it takes
you more than 6 weeks almost 7 weeks to
hit that first real value the second way
was the customer satisfaction score and
survey says what was their customer
satisfaction non-existent cuz they
didn't even track the data I'm giving
you the real stuff here ascension all
right so what percentage of customers do
they send or how much money were they
making from ascensions on the back end
survey says $0 because they didn't have
a back end when I say backend I mean
again the second thing or the thing
after the first thing they were selling
these are not pretty statistics that's
okay though this means that again for us
as investors huge opportunity for
improvement and that's where I get great
returns so product problem number one hi
churn what's churn Alex great question
it's the percentage of customers that
leave from this month to next month so
if I start the month with 100 customers
those same 100 customers a month later
how many of them choose to renew so if
95% of them choose to renew then I have
5% CH so this particular business was a
16we implementation so 16 weeks is how
long people were committing to on the
front end the problem was people weren't
even making it through the first thing
all the way the reason this is so
important is that is one of the largest
profit drivers in a business so let me
give you an example if we had two ways
to make X all right and X dollar from
keeping a customer means they stay for
three more months an xll from getting a
new customer means we have to pay to get
a your customer so we pay Mr YouTube or
we pay Mr Facebook $11,000 to get X or
we could pay $60 in staff or labor to
get the same xll so let's say I had to
pay for an hour of extra work per month
for my team to reach out or hop on a
phone call or two 30 minute phone calls
with the customer per month so we got 30
minutes * 2 30 minutes * 2 30 minutes
times 2 now you might be like man that's
a whole lot of work well let's say I'm
paying 20 bucks an hour and so this is
$20
this is $20 this is $20 going be like
wow again so much work but look at my
return the $60 to get the X versus
$1,000 to get the x is like 17 times
more profitable and if I'm an investor
which everyone who runs a business is
just on a micro level that's a way
better return and so I should be
allocating as much effort into that
bucket until I can't do any more in this
bucket and then go to my less efficient
ways of allocating Capital the biggest
and easiest problem that that we
identified was that their customer
success team was arbitrarily checking in
all right meaning they would just be
like hey what's going on let me go take
some of your time with No Agenda rather
than being one proactive and two knowing
what problem the person should already
be experiencing at this point in their
16we implementation cuz after all for
this particular product they were taking
everyone through a choreographed
experience except it wasn't a
choreographed experience which is not
the way to do business so if you know
that everyone in week one or two is
going to be suffering from one of these
two problems then you'd start the call
with saying hey most people this point
are at Point a or point B where are you
right now and they're automatically boom
you're right into it and they're like
this is value additive this is actually
helping me whereas you're like what's
going on John and it's just like uh
everything sucks and you're like oh why
does everything suck it's like you don't
seem informed you don't seem on top of
it you don't seem proactive and just by
doing this it sets an entirely different
tone for the customer relationship
because they're like these guys know
what they're doing and I feel better
about paying them and this is why
knowing that key Milestone that you're
driving towards that activation point
that time to First value is so key
because what you do is now all of your
communication and all of your efforts
are going to be targeted and optimized
to get this one single outcome right so
if I know that I need to get somebody to
get their first sale in 7 Days that's
high ticket in order to Triple their
lifetime value think about the resources
that I can put there so if someone goes
from $177,000 in LTV to $50,000 in LTV
which is much more like the stats were
for gym launch I have 20
$33,000 of resources that I have at my
disposal
of almost all profit to deploy to get
that one thing to happen so how many
resources do you think I should put
towards that a ton and so when we get on
the call we're like hey man let's send
that email out together right now they
like oh I don't know how to do it don't
worry I've got my tech guy with me here
we're going to connect the things that
you were probably struggling with were
you struggling with that oh my God this
is great wow they're on top of this cool
by the end of this call we're going to
send that email and then the likelihood
if they sent the email that they' make
the sale extremely high and that's how
you can drive towards this outcome if we
haven't even even Define that we're like
hey where are you at in the steps and
they're like this and you're like okay
cool well I haven't I haven't been able
to get to it yet okay don't worry about
it you know take your time I don't want
to overwhelm you like waste of time
waste of your time waste your staff's
time and you're ultimately not going to
extend the LTV and get them a good
experience problem number two survey
says no backend all right remember back
end is the second thing you sell what
these guys were doing and it's a it's a
very common mistake is to say hey after
the 16 weeks you can stay in the
community participate in all the stuff
that we have absolutely free and that's
usually just an attempt to sell more
people in the front end but it actually
creates lots of problems because what
you do is you create an endless
liability for a onetime income right so
if I say hey I'll personal train you for
free after 6 months if you pay the first
6 months it's like well sure I got the
first 6 months but now the rest of my
life if I'm want to be a man of my word
I have to train this person that's a
terrible unending liability even though
in the beginning it feels like it's a
good idea the other issue is that it
actually drives less client success so
let me explain if I know that I'm going
to have to to start paying more at a
certain time in the future I'm going to
be more likely to take action faster
right if I know that I can do it
whenever it means I do it never so the
idea is we want to have that sting at
the end that they know about so that we
can drive forward that time to Value so
you remember this little problem
solution cycle I was talking about we
got our problems we got our solution
well the good news is is that you can
actually use this to make more money
because if you properly solve the first
problem that they're presenting with
with your solution then you should also
introduce the next problem and here's
the key point you should know what that
problem is better than your customer
does why cuz you've done this a zillion
times and so they might think hey once I
lose weight all my problems are going to
be gone but that's not true there's a
lot of other things that they're going
to have to do as a result of that
they're going to have lose skin they're
going to have to change their wardrobe
now they want a sixpack rather than
losing weight you're just going to
introduce new problems and so after you
get someone down to their High School
weight the next solution you might have
for them would be our six-pack program
right and so you lead them down to their
ultimate goal but if you said hey when
someone walks in the door let me get you
a sixpack they're like dude I'm just
trying to get my high school weight and
so you have to meet them where they're
currently at and so this is how great
businesses continue to stay and profit
from customers for years is by knowing
well one effectively solving the first
problem you promised that you were going
to solve but then because you're so good
at solving the first problem actually
creating the second most businesses
don't solve the first problem and then
don't give themselves the opportunity to
solve the next one and as a result don't
make nearly as much money as they could
problem number three no metric tracking
seems like a common theme doesn't it and
given the uh the sheet that I showed you
earlier two out of the three were
basically not tracked or non-existent
right and honestly it's more common than
You' think you know what I can
absolutely promise you is that if you
don't measure a metric you're not going
to improve it and so one of the
beautiful things about once you start
tracking the metrics is that then you
can tie incentives to achieving those
metrics so both on an individual level
and at A Team level because incentives
is what's going to drive behavior and so
if you want your clients to have this
Milestone which we can now track with
metrics then we can incentivize and put
real resources behind making sure that
they actually achieve them and people
are willing to take the extra step go to
the extra mod to make sure this happens
because they get compensated for it but
if we don't have this up front we can't
do any of those things so we went over
three problems on their back end right
is that they weren't delivering on
promises and we knew that because they
had high turn they didn't even really
have a backend and they had no metrics
around success right you can predict how
good someone is at whatever skill is
based on the quality and the quantity of
the data they track and these guys track
none of it so we can kind of guess how
good the back end was and mind you
that's okay right like we still chose to
invest in this company because we saw
opportunity we saw the Spirit of the
founders we saw the desire to get better
and that's all I really need as long as
someone has work ethic and they have
desire to continue to improve cool we
can hop this stuff like that's why we do
what we do but if you're at like
$100,000 a year $500,000 a million a
year like it's normal to not have all
these pieces that's why it takes time to
build something great I don't want this
video to be taken as like I need to stop
what I'm doing and start doing this this
might not be the constraint of your
business but when you are there you'll
know what to do all right all right so
let's look at our handy danda data sheet
and now you know what's going on you
have some context you know what the
problems are and you know what our
current stats are with our weird before
put in the comments below what you think
you would do to fix these problems in
this
business I know you guys want to see the
after numbers and I'm going to show them
to you in a moment but before I do I'm
going to show you step by- step which
Solutions we did in what order so that
we actually achieve those solution
number
one improve C customer onboarding what
we did was they didn't have an
onboarding process for getting customers
to start they got sold and they got
tossed into this big bucket of other
customers it's obviously not good and so
what we did was we created a
choreographed onboarding process and
that was from the moment the sale closes
the moment they got off the phone all
the way until they begin implementation
so here's a fun stat for you people will
make a lasting impression about your
business within the first 24 hours after
the transaction wild so many people
maybe you watching this don't really
have any good communication or process
in the first 24 hours you might be like
oh yeah Sandra's going to touch base
with you in 4 days dude way too long
from now so if we sell someone we want
multiple points of communication
multiple points of open and closed loops
and what I mean by that is saying I'm
going to make this promise and I'm going
to keep this promise I'm going to make
this promise I'm going to keep this
promise I want to get like four five six
promises opened and fulfilled within the
first 24 hours cuz they're like man
these guys are on it even if something
that you would do all at once just take
that one thing that has six checkpoints
and make it six individual promises and
fulfill all of them there'll be so much
more impressed with you so we did a lot
of things to fix the back end and I had
my team actually write down the things
that we did in this business so that I
could have all the up-to-date details
for you so we did four things just to
improve this customer onboarding
experience so number one is that we
created a sales and CS team
synchronicity meaning we just aligned
both teams through the internal handoff
process we actually created a handoff
process so that it's like hey before we
go I'm going to connect with Sandra
Sandra is going to be your point of
contact and as a way of life I'm going
to give you this this thing that you can
give to your team bam famam book a
meeting from a meeting there should
never be a who's in no man's land they
should never be lost in the process they
should always know when the next
communication and the next
correspondence in terms of meeting is
going to be the next thing we did was we
started tracking all client goals so on
the sales call we would ask client what
their goal is we could understand why
they really wanted to buy this thing
then what we did was we passed it on to
the customer service team and when they
would hop on with the customer they'd be
like hey Johnny told me that you're
trying to retire your wife or hey Johnny
told me you wanted to clean your house
or whatever it was because you have a
wedding coming up and so you have this
clear reason why that we reiterate to
the customer and they're like wow I
didn't even have to tell this person
these guys are on it notice this
recurring theme is that they're like wow
these guys are airtight they go above
and beyond the third thing we did was
reset expectations with the customer so
the sales team is going to set
expectations obviously CU they're
selling but now that they're on the
other side of the pay wall you get to
reset the expectations and this should
be restating and reemphasizing exactly
what the salesperson said if you're
disconnect or to disjointed between
sales and CS it creates a lot of
dissonance and people like wait this
isn't what I signed up for and that's
what you don't want so right right now
you get a lot of cold feet or back outs
or people asking for refunds really
early it's usually because there's a
disconnect between first transaction or
first conversation and second
conversation then after resetting the
Expeditions we would resell them on the
purchase and this is important because
especially if it's a big purchase or
it's an involved purchase meaning a gym
membership isn't a big purchase but it's
a big commitment for the customer and so
we want to resell them on their why and
why it's going to be worth it tell them
some stories of people just like them
who were in the same position who saw
the outcome they ultimately want and the
fourth thing we did to improve the
onboarding process is that we set the
outline of steps to achieve the target
this is really important as we're saying
listen you want this thing let me tell
you what the steps are going to look
like and once you outline them we
continue to engage the client throughout
and so that whole process became
standardized and that was the fourth
process step that we used to improve the
onboarding process so you're like wait a
second we have one problem we have one
fix but this fix had four pieces to it
and the answer is yes is that you're not
going to fix churn with one thing it's
going to be many small things it's going
to be many golden BB's no silver bullets
product fix number
two over here so we implemented a CRM
and customer kpi tracking so if you
don't measure it you can't improve it or
rather you won't know even if you did we
have a lot of pros at holdco for
acquisition. comom and so when we take a
company on we're like listen let's put
all the systems in place and just
install that stuff so we can prove all
these metrics it's one of the easiest
ways that we just provide tons of value
and grow the Enterprise value of the
business overall so that's exactly what
we did and my team gave me some notes to
make sure I can give you even more
details on it so we started tracking
time to value and we started tracking
turn within the CRM automatically and so
this allowed us to in real time see how
many customers are hitting their
activation points and how many customers
are leaving there are two types of
indicators in business youve got leading
and lagging all lagging indicators are
like churn is that you don't fix churn
churn is a result so you have to do
things before the bad result happens to
fix it and so we know if someone doesn't
show up to the gym for a month that
becomes a leading indicator that they're
going to cancel if someone doesn't log
into Netflix for a long period of time
the likely the cancel goes up compared
to somebody who logs in and watches
every day one of the biggest unlocks in
a business especially in a recurring
Revenue business is figuring out what
are the leading indicators that get
someone to leave or stay and then
driving towards those leading indicators
to make sure that they don't leave and
with the CRM we were to automate
customer satisfaction surveys to all
customers in real time so we could see
how we were doing and segment it by
customer service representative and so
we could see okay the teams X but Sandy
ain't dragging her weight and she is
sandbagging true to her name and so we
have to give Sandy the boot or you know
get Sandy up to Snuff so that she
doesn't drag the whole team down but we
wouldn't be able to do that unless we
first were able to show Sandy hey Sandy
here's a stat that says that you are
worse than everyone else which means
that you have to do something better or
do something different than you
currently are why don't you follow the
process that everybody else is following
you'll probably be able to win too which
Segways almost perfectly
into commissioning the team for customer
success now a lot of people think that
the only people who should get
commissions are salese and I think
that's silly cuz believe it or not a lot
more of your profit is driven from
customer success so we did was with the
new CRM that we had implemented notice
how these things kind of happen in
sequence right like we had to hit the
CRM once we had the CRM then we had the
metrics now once we had the metrics we
could say hey these are your metrics
that you need to improve and this is the
Target or range that we want your metric
to be in and then we can commission them
weighted against how far into that range
they were so if you're at 100% you're
going to get 2x if you're at 50% you're
going to get X if you're at 0% you're
going to get 0x that's the idea with
this implementation program it was 16
weeks and if people are getting to 12
weeks then it would be weighted as 12
versus 16 so it's going to be weighted
at 75% I'm giving this as a simple
example but you can use this concept to
commission anyone for any particular
metric that you want to drive so the
whole idea is that once we had the few
metrics that we knew drove success we
would get more people to become
successful which got more people to stay
and pay longer and then would naturally
lead to the next problem which is that
we now had all these customers who were
finishing and had WIP or willingness to
pay and be sold more stuff and so that's
exactly what we did survey
says no back end built back end and so
what we did was we actually did
Implement a wall at the end of the 16
weeks so rather than saying it's 16
weeks and then after that you just get
this community we said you have to pay
to stay but we had driven all the other
metrics to make sure that people were
succeeding prior to the end of that so
we had people who were ready to move on
and saying hey what's the next thing and
so what we did was we rolled this out
really slowly because we didn't want to
shock the system and so right as soon as
we rolled it out we got 10% of customers
to ascend into the paying option which
is great and then as we tracked it over
the next 60 days we got it up to 27% of
people ascending into the paid option
this is pure created revenue on the back
end for no real additional cost besides
the cost of this commission that we had
to add the customer customer service
team and a onetime implementation of a
CRM so think about this on returns on
Capital you'd have this backend that
would continue to stack and stack and
stack over time and that then translates
to how much more you can market and sell
on the front end because if your cost to
acquire stays the same but you double
your LTV you can sometimes Market 10
times more not just twice as much so in
this particular instance cuz I told you
in the beginning that we added $6
million in Enterprise Value there's two
elements that add that really drove EV
one was when you add a recurring element
into a business it decreases the risk
that Revenue will disappear right so if
there's recurring Revenue it will become
more valuable and so this back end was a
recurring backend the second way that it
increase Enterprise Value is that not
just changing the nature of the revenue
but also changing the amount of profit
that we were making because that added
Revenue that we added to the back end
per month ultimately became profit to
the business on the bottom line and so
we have profit which then gets
multiplied by high multiple because it's
recurring and so those two things
together unlock even more Enterprise VI
value which is why some of this
incredibly boring stuff like customer
success can make you a ton of money so
let's talk data boom all right so I told
you before we had our time to Value this
should be time to value by the way but
it's okay so we have time to Value we
have our customer satisfaction and we
have Ascension before we had 47 days
non-existent and $0 so we did these
things and our time to Value went from
47 days to survey
says ugly ass hair 34 days our customer
satisfaction went from non-existent cuz
we weren't even tracking it to survey
says and we were able to do this because
we had implemented our CRM 98% so we
actually had pretty happy customers
overall which is pretty cool now if I
were to piece me all this out 98 I'm
like a little sus what I'm guessing is
this is probably right after our really
good choreographed onboarding is that we
did the customer satisfaction surveys
when you want to start parsing this out
you can start tracking them at uh week
zero week 2 week 4 week 8 week 12 now if
you do that many surveys people will
start resenting the fact you're asking
surveys so it's really kind of a push
pool of how able you are to collect the
data and how you collect the data so for
example if I already get on a call which
I do have regularly scheduled and say
hey by the way on a scale from 1 to 10
how likely would you be for a friend
they might give us a score now that
score might be different than if it was
sent to them voluntarily the other part
to add even more mud to the water the
only people who choose to respond to a
customer satisfaction survey are
typically either very happy or very sad
but you usually lose the metal
so this is just all to say it is a
metric that you can track it doesn't
mean it's the end all Beall so I could
try and like brag and say look 98% we
totally crushed it I I would suspect
that this is because we put it right
after a choreographed process which is
good all this tells me is that people
enjoyed the onboarding which is better
than not having one to begin with and
the last one was ascension all right and
if you're like wait where did these $6
million Enterprise Value come from gr
roll
please from $0 to $140,000 in backend
that we're able to create so this is
over 60 days so it's two months and this
will continue to increase but if we just
split this in half in it's $70,000 a
month in profit that we were able to add
to the business over the year that's
just under a million bucks and if you
multiply that by six which would
probably be a standard Enterprise Value
multiple for a company of this size then
we added about $6 million in Enterprise
Value to the business but we could not
have done this one if we hadn't fixed
all of these other things first we
improved the customer onboarding we then
implemented the CRM and created kpi
tracking so that we could then
commission the customer success team on
the activation points and the leading
indicators that would ultimately Drive
success for the clients and we had the
customer satisfaction surveys that we
could also Implement to make sure that
people and their reps in any ways even
from a behavioral standpoint just them
knowing that whenever they talk to
somebody they're going to get surveyed
afterwards and you can segment it by rep
it just keeps people more honest so
they're more on their game they're
prepare for the calls they say hey I
listened to your last call I have these
steps I outlined how we're going to
support you and how we're going to
reverse engineer your success all of
these things were only possible from
these first three steps and then when we
make the next ask because we fulfilled
our first promises a certain percentage
of those customers were willing to say
yes in the beginning it was 10% and now
it's 27% and it'll be even more in the
future as we continue to get more and
get better processes in place to win and
if this stuff was interesting to you you
might be wondering why I have the mosy
Lisa in my hands this is a mega video
that I just made of how to build a $100
million plus company and if that sounds
just ah I'm showing you some hints
there's way more where that came from
just click on my face and you'll find
out more